Je suis parti en Amérique, ma sœur Rose
rêve juste de venir me voir là-bas un
jour oui c'est ce que s'il vous plaît passez par ici
merci s'il vous plaît
cher anglais c'est difficile pour moi de croire
que vous lisez ceci à des milliers de
kilomètres à travers la mer J'étais bon  de voir que
tu as enfin reçu une lettre de la maison
aujourd'hui j'ai oublié de vérifier être toujours là
après le dîner où as-tu dansé pour moi
tony m'a aidé à sentir que j'ai une
vie ici que je n'avais pas avant de le rencontrer
tout le monde est parti et ish  Je n'ai
personne à soigner oh j'ai peur de
ne pas revenir en
laisse c'est Jim Farrell un grand
plaisir de te rencontrer ils ont des plages
à Brooklyn c'est pas pareil
mais tu es paralysé dessus c'est un résultat attrape
je  J'avais imaginé une vie différente de la
mienne quelle est ta vie ici pourrait être
tout aussi bien mieux
Tony je veux que tu saches que
non
oh